- I'm here with none other
than Natalie Portman!
(audience clapping)
Oh my God!
Natalie recently wrote a
fantastic children's book
called Natalie Portman's Fables,
which is why I thought I'd challenge her
to a game called,
are you able to label this fable?
(upbeat music)
♪ Are you able to label this fable ♪
(laughing)
Oh my God,
here's how it works.
We'll each get a clue that leads us
like a trail of breadcrumbs
to the title of a famous fable.
If Natalie or I can name
that fable, we get a point.
If we don't know or give the wrong answer,
the other person can steal for two points.
Uh oh, plot twist.
Most points wins.
If Natalie wins,
her photo will be added to
the Blake Shelton wall of champions
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
Not many people on it,
Natalie, no pressure.
(laughing)
Immediately following the show
that will happen,
but that's not all, if Natalie wins,
the left side of the
audience is going home
with a special prize.
If I win the right side is getting it,
but wait, we need a host
'cause I can't do both, exactly.
Here to lend a hand is a very funny woman
whom you can see each Wednesday
in The Goldbergs on ABC,
let's give it up for Wendi McLendon-Covey!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Oh, you win for best outfit.
- Well, thank you, you
win for sexiest audience.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes!
- And hello, Natalie.
(laughing)
All right, are we jumping right in?
- Let's, okay wait, so here we go.
So you already said hello to Wendi.
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Yes.
- So thank you for being here,
first of all and in the
most fabulous suit ever
and for hosting our game.
Take it away you can go.
- Okay, first question is for Natalie.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Uh oh.
- If the slipper fits
this handsome fella will
ask for the hand of blank.
- Cinderella.
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] All right.
(dinging)
One point for Natalie.
- Boo, okay.
(laughing)
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Okay,
next question is for Kelly.
She skipped merrily off,
not abiding the wood,
that's when the Wolf saw--
- Little Red Riding Hood.
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Yes,
(dinging)
correct.
- Yes!
- Point for Kelly.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes.
- Again--
- No pressure Natalie,
you're doing fine, don't worry about it.
- Back to Natalie.
So different she floated as,
so different she floated
along as a suckling,
she'd grow to be gorgeous this blank.
- The Ugly Little Duckling?
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Yes.
(dinging)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes,
The Ugly Duckling, yes.
- The Ugly Ducking?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes, yes.
(audience cheering)
- Okay, next one for Kelly.
- Nicely done, whatever Natalie.
(laughing)
- Thanks.
Good luck.
(laughing)
- All right, Kelly you're up.
The mattresses rose as high as a tree,
but sleep would not come for the,
- Princess and the Pea.
(dinging)
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Boom!
- Boom, I loved that one actually
as a kid.
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Oh.
- It's a really good one.
- I know.
Did anybody ever do that--
- Did you see that musical?
Did you--
- That's the best musical.
- Oh, did you ever do it
though when you were a kid,
did you hide something under your mattress
to be like I'm totally
a princess, I felt it.
(laughing)
No, I didn't do it either,
that would have been so stupid.
I didn't do it either, Natalie.
- How weird.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Okay.
(laughing)
Again, back to Natalie.
To town with his cow a nice serene walk
and later a climb for blank.
- Jack and the Beanstalk.
(dinging)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes!
(audience cheering)
- Oh, oh,
this contest is neck and neck.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay.
- Last one for Kelly.
- Okay.
- This doesn't quite rhyme
to tell you the truth,
a lesson learned by blank.
- Winnie the Pooh?
I don't know because
I'm trying to rhyme with
(buzzing)
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Yeah.
- I don't, I don't know--
- The Boy Who Cried Wolf.
- That is, y'all are trying
to get her on the wall!
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Which
doesn't rhyme with truth.
- They are trying to get her wall.
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Oh man.
Whatever.
- [Wendi McLendon-Covey] Well,
it sounds like Natalie won.
- Oh my God, I call BS!
(laughing)
- To be fair,
I don't feel good about it.
- I mean.
- It's not a win I can accept.
- Well, here's the thing,
I mean, what I meant by that
was congratulations Natalie,
your framed photo is going on
the Blake Shelton wall of
champions who beat Kelly Clarkson
'cause my producers hate me.
- Wow.
- And that will happen after
the show, don't you worry.
And I'm fine about it.
All right y'all of course
there are no losers
at the Kelly Clarkson Show.
So everyone in the audience
is getting a treat,
Lafco New York creates
luxurious natural candles,
body care and home fragrance products
with scents ranging from frosted pine
to white maple bourbon.
Ooh, that sounds like a
good drink, I'm just saying.
You'll want to check out Lafco's
limited edition holiday collection
because you're all
getting a $200 gift card!
(audience cheering)
What?
Y'all Natalie's book is called
Natalie Portman's Fables.
It's in stores and online right now.
Thank you so much for dropping in Natalie,
I love the book.
- Thank you so much, Kelly.
So nice to be on and meet you.
- Yeah, have a blessed day girl.